fünf todesopfer fünf menschen die beim
zugunglück in der bayerischen idylle von
garmisch partenkirchen ihr leben
verloren haben mehr als 200 menschen
haben ihnen jetzt in einem
gedenkgottesdienst gedacht zwei der vier
getöteten frauen waren flüchtlinge aus
der ukraine ein 13-jähriger junge
stammte aus der region
dort sieht man in gottesdienst
vereinzelt sah man sich dort die
menschen die sich in den armen gelegen
haben ja die gedenkfeier wurde wegen der
zwei verstorbenen ukrainischen frauen
neben der deutschen auch in der
ukrainischen sprache abgehalten und wir
sprechen jetzt mit kalk heim unserem
reporter denn jetzt kommt heraus genau
in dem streckenabschnitt wurde das
unglück passiert ist war eine baustelle
geplant warum
patricia du hast das richtig
angesprochen für ende des monats am 25
juni waren hier gleich bauarbeiten
geplant ein wenige tage einen tag vor
dem g7 gipfel hier in ellmau und zwar so
genannte gleis lage berechtigungen das
klingt etwas sperrig aber da muss man
sich so vorstellen
jedes gleichheit ja gewissermaßen eine
höhe oder breite die eingehalten werden
müssen und das sollte hier wohl
korrigiert werden man muss ja so
vorstellen die im straßenverkehr mit
bodenwellen aber ob das jetzt dann auch
zum entgleisen des zuges geführt hat das
muss jetzt von einem gutachter geklärt
werden der im auftrag der
staatsanwaltschaft münchen zwei tätig
ist denn dafür ist es noch viel zu früh
um das jetzt hier genau fixe zusagen
soll das ist die ursache wir sind jetzt
hier fertig und das wird auch noch
mehrere wochen und auch im vermutlich
mehrere monate dauert bis es da
endgültig zu einer unglücksursache kommt
karl heim für uns hat an der
unglücksstelle karl wir sprechen gleich
weiter gemeinsam wollen wir aber einmal
auf diesen unfall schauen auf diesen
schrecklichen unfall der fünf menschen
das leben gekostet hat
das katastrophale ausmaß eines horror
unfalls garmisch partenkirchen tiefe
fassungslosigkeit
unfassbare trauer fünf menschen sterben
in den trümmern
unter ihnen ein kind ein 13-jähriger der
sein ganzes leben noch vor sich hat und
noch immer gibt es keine ursache noch
immer warten die angehörigen wartet
deutschland auf die antworten nach der
quälenden frage warum das paradiesische
garmisch patenkirchen am vergangenen
freitag schauplatz einer katastrophe
kurz nach 12 uhr mittags rollt der rb 5
94 58 im bayerischen urlaubsort los um
13 uhr 26 hätte die regionalbahn den
münchner hauptbahnhof erreichen sollen
der zug wird nie in der landeshauptstadt
ankommen bereits wenige minuten nach
abfahrt geschieht das unglück dass fünf
personen das leben kostet der zug mit
doppelstockwagen biegt in eine
langgezogene kurve ein und entgleist was
folgt eine tödliche verwüstung neben den
fünf toten werden 15 schwer verletzt ins
krankenhaus gebracht insgesamt spricht
die polizei von 44 verletzten die fragen
die nun alle beschäftigen
konnte das passieren wer trägt die
schuld die politik verspricht lückenlose
aufklärung
jetzt muss ermittelt werden was die
ursache ist
das sind die zuständigen behörden
uns ist zunächst einmal wichtig dass er
alle die verletzt sind bald wieder
gesunden dieses
dramatische ereignis wird umfassend
untersucht und aufgeklärt werden und
erst am ende wenn man weiß was genau die
ursache war kann man schlüsse daraus
ziehen klar ist dass dies restlos
aufgeklärt und aufgearbeitet wird
bisher scheint man davon allerdings noch
weit entfernt
ein anschlag werde derzeit
ausgeschlossen über ein lockeres
gleisbett wird gemunkelt außer
vermutungen allerdings nichts die
unsicherheit über den auslöser einer
katastrophe eine belastung für die
region und die angehörigen der opfer
unter den opfern eine 51 jährige aus
hessen sowie eine 70 jährige frau deren
herkunft noch ungeklärt ist auch lukas m
überlebt das unglück nicht er wird nur
13 jahre und ein kind unter den toten
sind auch die 30 jährige alexandra c und
svetlana es 90 beide ukrainerinnen
geflohen aus putins hölle gestorben in
der bayrischen regional der schock und
der schmerz sitzen tief im
paradiesischen garmisch partenkirchen
und über allem schwebt die frage warum
und an der unglücksstelle kelkheim
unsere reporter uns zugeschaltet kalt
der gedenkgottesdienst viele berührt
zwei der opfer waren ja aus der ukraine
vom krieg geflüchtet wie geht es den
verletzten
ja eine frau schwebt nach meinen
informationen immer noch in lebensgefahr
ansonsten geht es ja allen körperlich so
weit wieder besser dass sie nicht mehr
um ihr leben bangen müssten aber
natürlich dieser seelischen schock sagt
psychische schock das wird natürlich ein
leben lang andauern menschen die da in
diesem zug gewesen sind das erlebte
verarbeiten müssen ja wie gesagt ich war
gestern abend bei diesem gottesdienst in
partenkirchen ja das war schon sehr
eindrucksvoll das gut auch in
ukrainischer sprache
abgehalten und
ja da wurde den beiden gedacht und habe
ich auch jemanden getroffen der die
beiden hier in bayern ankommen lassen
hat ein herr meier 95 jahre alt der hat
hier für die gemeinde oberaudorf wo die
beiden untergebracht waren hat er ist
einer der wenigen der russisch spricht
und hat dann sozusagen für die beiden
hier hat den beiden geholfen hier
anzukommen sie
hat sie auch bei ihren
vorstellungsgesprächen gleitet und ja
das ist eine das ist wirklich sehr sehr
tragisch und man weiß jetzt auch
mittlerweile genaueres über diesen
unfall über diesen unglückstag
alexandra war gerade auf einer im
hausbesichtigung geräte wo ein
unternehmer ein haus für zehn
ukrainische flüchtlinge bereitstellen
wollte und sie wollte nach hause zu
ihrem siebenjährigen sohn fahren und ja
ist dann genau dann vergnügt um diese
frohe botschaft zu verkünden dass sie da
wohl eine bleibe haben die noch etwas
renoviert werden musste ja das ist
wirklich tragisch mann flieht vor putins
bomben und kommt dann ihren einer
regional bei den bayern ums leben
ja wirklich schrecklich
kalbheim unser reporter dort an der
unglück stelle weil garmisch
partenkirchen dieses unglück dass fünf
menschen das leben gekostet hat die
ursache muss noch aufgeklärt werden
herzlichen dank dir für deine
information